تجمعت الحشود في منتزه بيدمونت بأتلانتا في
نهاية هذا الأسبوع للاستمتاع بالشمس
والهواء النقي ، وهو أمر رائع لرؤية
الجميع والاستمتاع
بمشاهد الطقس المماثلة في مناطق أخرى بما في ذلك
مدينة نيويورك والمركز الوطني في
واشنطن العاصمة.
سبعة أسابيع ، ويا لها من فرصة أفضل لل
زول وزيارة عا
مة الأمة ، أم
ى الأمريكيون الآخرون عطلة نهاية الأسبوع الأولى في مايو في الدعوة إل
عملية إعادة الافتتاح لتسريع أح
هذه الأحداث.  بول مينيسوتا
وقد بدأوا في الإغلاق ، إنه أمر
غير دستوري ،
إنه يقتل عددًا أكبر مما تعتقد
أنك تنقذه ، لكن بعض مسؤولي الصحة
يختلفون مع هذا الرأي.
في آب (أغسطس) ،
نعتقد أنه بالنسبة للعديد من الولايات التي يتم
إعادة فتحها ، من المحتمل أن تكون
هناك زيادة في عدد الإصابات
نتيجة لإعادة الفتح ويقول بعض
العاملين الطبيين إنهم لا يستطيعون التعامل مع
زيادة في الحالات التي نعيد فتحها.
سعة تصل إلى 6000 سرير في وحدة العناية المركزة ،
ليس لدينا القدرة على القيام بذلك ، فنحن
بحاجة إلى أن نكون أذكياء بشأن كيفية إعادة
فتحنا.  الاختبار الذي يبحث عن
العلامات الجينية لفيروس كورونا
وهذا الذي يختبر الأجسام المضادة
سأعطيك لونًا أبيض باردًا أول شيء
ستلاحظه هو أن اختبار الأجسام المضادة
يتطلب دمًا من أجل  لقد كانت مجرد كزة ،
ولكن بعد ذلك انظر إلى جميع الخطوات التي
تحدث بعد ذلك ، يتم أخذ دمي
إلى المختبر ثم يتم لفه في
جهاز طرد مركزي ، كنت تنظر إلى مصل الدم
الخاص بي ، وهو الجزء الواضح الذي قد يحتوي على
أجسام مضادة إذا  لقد تم
الكشف سابقًا عن طريقة اكتشاف ذلك أمرًا
رائعًا ، فقط خذ بعضًا من مصل الدم الخاص بي
وضعه في نفس أنبوب الاختبار مثل
الفيروس وشاهد ما سيحدث إذا كان لديك
أجسام مضادة ضد ذلك
ستلتزم وسنكون كذلك  قادر على اكتشاف
أن د.  جون روبيك هو
المدير الطبي لبنك الدم في
مستشفى جامعة إيموري في أتلانتا حيث
أمارس كجراح أعصاب ، تمكنت من
الحصول على هذا الاختبار لأنني ما زلت أعمل
كطبيب في إيموري
ويعتبر العاملون في مجال الرعاية الصحية في منتهى السهولة
خطر الإصابة بـ kovat 19:00 إليك ما يحدث
في جسمك عندما تصاب
بالخط الأزرق ، وهي المدة التي يعيش فيها الفيروس
عادةً بداخلك ،
ألقِ نظرة على الخط الأخضر مبكرًا على
ظهور الأجسام المضادة IgM لكنها تختفي
بعد فترة وجيزة وبعد ذلك  الخط الأحمر
هو الجسم المضاد IgG
الذي يظهر بعد إزالة العدوى
وقد يوفر مناعة
لمدى القوة التي لا
نعرفها حتى الآن نحن نعلم أنه بالنسبة
لفيروسات كورونا الأخرى مثل الأجسام المضادة لـ SARS
استمرت من سنتين إلى ثلاث سنوات و
كان لمتلازمة الشرق الأوسط التنفسية العمدة
وجود الأجسام المضادة لمدة ثلاث سنوات تقريبًا
ولكن مع هذا الفيروس التاجي الجديد ،
لا يزال من السابق لأوانه معرفة القيمة الحقيقية لإجراء
الاختبار على ما أعتقد إذا كنت
إذا كنت إيجابيًا في هذا الاختبار ، فهذا
يشير إلى أنك تعرضت لذلك يمكن أن
يمنحك القليل من راحة البال ،
أعتقد أنك تعلم أنك تعرف
أن COFF كان لدي قبل أسبوعين والذي كان
مشقوقًا حقًا تسعة عشر  أشر إلى
أنك تعرف أن بعضًا من جهات الاتصال الخاصة بك
يجب أن
يختبر هذا ولكن ربما الأهم من ذلك أن
د.  أخبرني روبك شيئًا لم أفكر فيه
حقًا من قبل ذلك إذا كانت نتيجة
الاختبار إيجابية للأجسام المضادة ، فهذا
يعني أنك تعاملت مع هذه
العدوى وتغلبت عليها ، ومن المحتمل أنك إذا
تعرضت لها مرة أخرى فسوف تهزمها
مرة أخرى  بالنسبة لي ، لا يزال هذا الجزء
علامة استفهام مفتوحة ، لقد اختبرت سلبيًا
بواسطة إحدى التقنيات ، وهي الشركة الألمانية الوحيدة حتى
الآن التي حصلت على الموافقة
التنظيمية لبدء تجارب اللقاحات المحتملة
ضد kovat 19 ، وهي أيضًا واحدة من عدد
قليل من الشركات في العالم  من أجل
أن تكون بالفعل في التجارب السريرية ،
قالت الشركة يوم الأربعاء إنها
أكملت الجرعات الأولى من
اللقاح التجريبي الجديد الذي يسمى
int16 للمجموعة الأولى لهذه الجرعات الأولى كانت 12
شخصًا وتم تطعيمهم جميعًا الآن
، كما تقول الشركة في الثانية.  في
مرحلة التجربة يريدون الانتقال إلى مجموعة أكبر
تضم حوالي 200 شخص تتراوح
أعمارهم بين 18 إلى 55 عامًا ، ونريد
اختبار الكثير من الأشياء في تلك المرحلة الثانية
من التجربة ولكن بشكل خاص ما إذا
كان  اللقاح التجريبي آمن بالفعل الآن
، لا يزال من غير الواضح في أي نقطة من الوقت
سيكون هذا اللقاح جاهزًا
للاستخدام العام ولكن على المستوى العالمي من خلال
العمل التقني مع شركة الأدوية الأمريكية
Pfizer وكل من Pfizer وعلى التكنولوجيا لديها بالفعل  قالوا
إنهم يريدون أيضًا بدء التجارب السريرية
في الولايات المتحدة في انتظار
الموافقة التنظيمية هناك والتي يعتقدون أنها
ستحدث قريبًا جدًا
، وأعتقد أننا نتعلم بسرعة كبيرة لأن
هذا الفيروس لا يتصرف مثل
الفيروسات التي اعتاد عليها الأطباء آدم
فريدمان وجوزيف  رأى
أطباء الأمراض الجلدية لدينا في جامعة جورج واشنطن
بعض الحالات غير العادية ، ومن
المثير للاهتمام أن
مريض جاء الأسبوع الماضي يشكو من بقع أرجوانية حمراء
على أصابع القدم ، يطلق عليه Co
vid toes كما هو الحال في فيروس كورونا ، وهو
مرض الجهاز التنفسي المميت ،
لذا فإن الشيء الرئيسي هو ذلك  يحاكي ما
نسميه Pernis OSIS وهو رد فعل
في الجلد لدرجات الحرارة الباردة ولقمة الصقيع
ضرر أقل قليلاً من قضمة الصقيع
لكن نعم ، يكشف أطباء المفهوم المماثل في
جميع أنحاء العالم عن المزيد
من الأعراض المحتملة لـ kovat 19 لهذا
الغرض ، كما يعمل أطباء الأمراض
الجلدية في أدوار مختلفة
لم يتوقعوها أبدًا في حياتهم
المهنية بأكملها ، بما في ذلك Freedman.
إن غرسة الأنف
التي من شأنها إطلاق أكسيد النيتريك من
خلال أنوف مرضى كوبان
يعتبر أكسيد النيتريك إشارة مركزية لتنظيم
الاستجابة المناعية ، ويقول إن هناك المزيد من
الاختبارات التي يجب إجراؤها ولكن يأمل
أن تساعد التكنولوجيا الأشخاص هنا
في DMV لدينا الكثير  من المرضى
الذين أراكم قد يستفيدون حقًا من أخبارنا
Victoria Sanchez ABC 7 News